what can make you angry
a lot of things first thing that comes
to mind is losing anything
have you ever cried
when I was young I cried many many times
after after that let's go watch the
games yeah you meet many well-known and
famous people what was the most
memorable acquaintance
um I'm not sure if it's politically
correct to say but the most memorable I
think was
Crown Prince of Saudi Arabia he was a
very imposing figure
yes and who would you like to meet from
people of the past
people from
yeah I don't know
okay
um do you like being famous
I
would say I don't aspire to being famous
but overall it's more positive than me
who would you like to be if you if you
hadn't been Magnus Carlos
I don't know Messi
Barcelona by the way yeah
yes and what is your greatest fear
very superficially I've always had good
health so if I were to lose that
would not be good yes and last question
what makes you happy Harmony
thank you